hi this time I'm going to say some
points on the job I can't cover
everything because
you know after I've made the film I'll
go inside and I'll think oh why didn't I
say this why did I say that but the
points I'm giving you are common ones
that I see from all over the world and
people who think they're doing following
the awama weapons may have lots of these
points everyone actually and more but my
job is to polish you and to make you
better and in turn cytosense it will be
happy that instead of using warmer
weapons
and the ones I've sent you taught him
are not getting destroyed but they're
actually getting polished and made
better and in time you'll feel at one
with your weapons and then it becomes
more spiritual become more
lighter and happier in life because
you're starting to become one with more
than just a Ken and a joke but the
universe hopefully itself and others
around you
okay so I'm going to try to cover these
quite a few points on the Joe
the biggest uh bug bear that I get is I
never saw a sight of sense you do this
and yet I see his students I don't care
if they're sixth seventh bands or what
Downs they are very few
um
get
the point correct
I have a lot of Joe films out there and
I started thinking I better make some
Ken ones because
seems to be Joe heavy on my YouTube
channel anyhow
the first thing is
when you're about to start
I get annoyed with people they've got
their Joe they put it down they look to
see where it should go
in my book I I say this is a human being
weakness not a martial artist's attitude
I never see psycho Sensei looking down
so please check yourself video yourself
check so
this is no good when they finish say a
Carter
I see this again
so what is the film
oh my dogs decided to talk to us but
that's okay I keyed her in daily life
so
please look at these points
that's uh Don't Look Down you should
know where your Joe is all right
it's a cure and you do need to look down
well look down but know that you're
doing out of out of an act so I'm gonna
look down though it's not quite right I
need to move out you know
three centimeters it wasn't worth really
the trouble to be that paranoid
okay your arm
is the same as if your hand was over
your foot
so
so you don't need you don't need to look
down I know I'm going on a lot about
this but look at these Southern Obama
teachers it sounds like I'm really
saying that I'm the best and they're not
I'm not saying that I'm just saying they
haven't learned the weaknesses
superb so I could have is the thing with
me is I'm dyslexic so I've had to really
sort of work it out what I get from such
a sensei
and he used to teach us more perhaps off
than that and he did on it but he would
tell you a lot of stories in the
evenings but certain things you know but
he never said about looking down
there's something I've observed I've
also observed this from high ranked
teachers
that the hands too loose
if you can't close it bring it up
if it has to be here
and it's loose
[Applause]
it's loose
don't bring it up
you need to have the whole hand around
the Joe
the whole thing
this is the next thing and this comes
from the
uh
this comes from the Ken problem the
trigger fingers
the fingers again they should be closed
or just a little they shouldn't be have
this this finger I notice it a lot on
number nine and the 31 Calcutta
they do this
should be
if you get it right it won't go all the
way around
it it it it won't completely close but
you don't want it straight
the other thing is on a on a Oceano ski
a lot of people so they know where the
end of the Joe is they put their thumb
on it this is not I keep I keep yeah
this is this is
from jodo Missouri it's another martial
art so please if you check to make sure
you're not doing this
so a little bit but not much with the
fingers the next problem
there's lots of problems they might not
be in the order that they should be in
but you'll have to work them out
they go down a little way they pick it
up off the ground
if another Joe is working with you
you're doing Kumi Joe they could knock
that out of your hand
you go down they can knock it out your
hand so don't pick it up
again that's that's lazy because you
don't realize that you have to work you
have to perhaps do yoga even
to to achieve it
the fingers start here
you go you enter forward a little bit
and you keep going forward
so it's the motion
okay
don't turn the body two sideways
I'm looking here now I'm not looking
there so this is abnormal this is not
natural
I sense that I could I was very simple
so I just simply said we make it
complicated us
consensus I could always uh natural
I said on other films this hand needs to
come past you
not here
on the ushero ski number three just
just when you put your Joe down just put
it outside the foot a little
let your hand judge Where You Are what
your eyes you don't need to look
different
the time the hand is flat
flat is when you
it's under the arm it's in the direction
of there the pit of their stomach
foreign
ski out of the 20 where you don't look
behind you you keep your head forward or
slightly to the side it's supposed to be
a poke toward people uh people off who
you've sense are getting too close to
you
so don't look back
Suzuki same thing
don't bring the body round
don't bring the body around to get the
job
this Gap at this end don't make it too
big let the these two these two fingers
they're the important to the others are
not so important when gripping so you
don't want these to be loose whereas the
wrong end is gripping these can be a
little bit more loose
it's very difficult nothing's easy in
hiki though is it
the same as with the can show nucomy
are the elbows out can you keep the
elbows in is it high or is it low
try to feel the energy going upwards
the
three
on the renzokuchi Comey
feel that you're hitting a rubber ball
or a rubber tire on the first cut to
give you the energy to naturally let it
go into the second cut and the hands do
the same as if you had it with Ken
fill that bounce
keep the Joe in front of your Center
if you get the Joe in front of your
Center
do not
let it come off the side of your head
come straight down your nose
do not turn the body so that the Joe is
outside
of your body line in front of your
Center
number nine all these points you'll find
in my Joseph is they're all on YouTube
they're all numbered so you can go to
any number and it'll tell you the
weaknesses in there
so the things that are important are
number number nine
you must look first
and then ski don't ski leaving the Joe
get near your face it must go past
there's different skis there's some on
this level where they must go past in
case somebody hits it
not the hair or else if they hit it
looks what's going to happen
okay
the um
or here above the head if you're not
going to go all the way past dip dip
different skis then you need a bit of
other head so that it turns
another weak point is
a ski and then a block
this is too close again to the Head the
hands are too close look
foreign
are these too wide can you can you keep
them in
why it's okay as long as you know you
don't let them just become free you know
it's uh
keep them as close as you can
so here's a problem I see
it looks all okay it's too close to the
head and it's like sitting back on this
barcel that I was talking about with the
Kent
[Music]
you're fine if you keep doing that it'll
feel like you've got a stop start the
techniques all the time it should be
able to be a continuous flow
push up high
get your energy flowing get your
adrenaline going one day you'll connect
and it'll be like connecting into the
coke you so think of the heaven going up
to the heavens
when it feels good speed will come you
don't have to find speed
keep it in front of your Center
now sometimes with the Joe you'll find
that the bent leg is a little bit bent
as long as you're not sort of resting on
it then that's fine we're not resting on
it
you catch it
and again the hand
the hand is not here with his finger a
hand
is open when it catches it but it's
swiftly closes
it's in exactly the same position as
number nine and 31.
now in the early days had a sense used
to take it much further back
like this
but now if you do the fourth Kumi Joe
what he introduced
you'll find that the body has to twist
to get that position that final position
but if it goes too far behind you
'll find that
the body has to sort of twist
[Music]
put it in the same position as number
nine and the 31 it'll be on the line of
your your body the line of your body
so as you move in
this low I know it's fitting my body
it's fitting my body
it might save a millisecond or two but
it's an alignment so so sometimes you
know in the early films you'll see that
and you'll be saying Tony's
contradicting what I see scientists
actually doing remember what I said I
was with him for 27 years or following
him for that long and he changed a lot
and uh and I suppose I've looked at it I
don't know I'll just look at it but
these are the points that I'm trying to
say what I found
if I can remember it's this side for
number nine and the 31 and it's easy to
remember this side for katata Tom Roots
isn't it
you know if I've got this one and
sometimes this one I've got to try and
remember two things
um
so by doing the fourth Kumi Joe try it
and if you do that then and see if that
helps
let me think what else there is
[Music]
um
fit this hand
is usually open
but when you're at the top it then
closes when you bring it down
elbow
[Music]
trigger fingers
so there'll be lots of points there
um
and I I could go on but uh
if you get that then lots of things will
start to you'll start noticing
weaknesses in in all the suburbs so
start noticing things that you're adding
in there that you don't need to
there's uh there's all sorts of things
with the cannon Joe that's in there
three so I'll do that again just so you
can see it shapes of my body it shapes
of my body
[Music]
okay so I've tried to cover a sort of a
and a range of uh Joe things there I'd
like you to work on and um
once you get this energy going it will
get you somewhere
foreign
Carter usually good for beginners but
it'll be good for you to just check
yourself for a few things you know other
fingers out you know is the block high
enough are you looking down every time
you you stop
and down
are you picking it up
you're going to it
are you 50 50. are you leaning forward
so when you send in the videos If you
send in the videos please send them in
one at a time as far as the can well
separate them anyway if you send them
all together
um get you put get a YouTube channel if
you haven't got one put them on YouTube
send me the link and then I can just
click on the link look at them and I can
make notes and let you know what I see
and um if it's all satisfactory then
you'll get the different levels that
you're working towards everybody has to
start level one because to me Cebu is
the most important thing
the Awaso practices I just as I said the
the can in the Ken's case they're just
the
suburbs in motion with the Joe it's a
much more perhaps exciting you've got
Carters
Jimmy Joe's kentai Joe's it just goes on
forever but you will find stop starts
and um and difficult to move if you if
you've got a lot of these stopping the
technique and having to restart it again
okay so I hope that helps and I will add
to these films as I feel fit
thank you for your time